Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Hello, everyone. I hope you had a wonderful Christmas and we have two festive treats coming up for you today and on Thursday. These are two halves of a show that we recorded at the Royal Albert Hall on the 18th of October with a full choir, a full orchestra. So this is going to be aside from of course those immortal episodes in which I sang, the first Rest is History episodes with musical accompaniment. The first episode, today's episode is on Mozart.
感谢收听《历史的剩余》（The Rest is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告内容、系列节目的抢先收听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社群，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好。希望你们过了一个美好的圣诞节。今天和周四，我们将为您献上两场节日特辑。这两场节目是我们于 10 月 18 日在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅（Royal Albert Hall）录制的，现场有完整的合唱团和交响乐队。所以，除了我唱歌的那些不朽集数之外，这将是《历史的剩余》首次配有乐队伴奏的节目。第一集，也就是今天的节目，主题是莫扎特。
Thursday's episode will be on Beethoven. Enjoy. Thursday's episode will be on Beethoven. Enjoy! The The The The The The The The The The The The The The Good evening, and welcome to The Rest Is History. And Dominic, ladies and gentlemen, I think you'll agree that was quite something. We've had many great musical moments on The Rest Is History. One thinks of Diamonds Are A Girl's Best Friend, sung by me, and more recently Don't Cry For Me Argentina, which was also sung by me. But I think, I mean, that wasn't bad. That was kind of up there, wasn't it?
周四的节目将是贝多芬。尽情欣赏吧。周四的节目将是贝多芬。尽情欣赏吧！晚安，欢迎收听《历史的剩余》。多米尼克，女士们先生们，我想你们会同意刚才那段真是相当了不起。我们在《历史的剩余》中经历过许多伟大的音乐时刻。人们会想起由我演唱的《钻石是女孩最好的朋友》（Diamonds Are A Girl's Best Friend），以及更近一点由我演唱的《阿根廷，别为我哭泣》（Don't Cry For Me Argentina）。但我觉得，我的意思是，那场演出可不赖。可以说是相当高水准了，对吧？
Ladies and gentlemen, please do not indulge him. That was not in that league at all, Tom. I think it is... I think we can all agree on that. That was Mozart's Symphony No. 25. It was played by the brilliant orchestra that I have behind me, the Academy of St Martin in the Fields. We have the Philharmonia Chorus. CHEERING AND APPLAUSE And above all, the most important person who's on the stage tonight, the person whose idea for this evening this was, the person who has made it possible, and that is our majestic
女士们先生们，请不要纵容他。汤姆，那根本不在一个档次上。我想这是……我想大家对此都会认同。那是莫扎特的《第25号交响曲》。它是由我身后的这支杰出乐队——圣马田室内乐团（Academy of St Martin in the Fields）演奏的。我们还有爱乐合唱团（Philharmonia Chorus）。（欢呼与掌声）最重要的是，今晚舞台上最重要的人物，这个美妙夜晚的创意发起人，让这一切成为现实的人，那就是我们威严的
conductor Oliver Zephman. I've been a fan of the podcast since the beginning. Actually, in the past life, I have a history undergraduate degree, but I've been a fan of the podcast since the beginning. Actually in the past life I had a history undergraduate degree, but not anymore. And I go and touch upon Dominic because there are so many interesting, exciting stories in classical music. People know music a little bit, but actually if you don't go to concerts or you don't have much exposure to it, how do you get into it? And so this was a perfect opportunity to talk about two of the most important composers ever, probably two of the most important cultural figures ever, and their lives also found a very interesting
指挥奥利弗·泽夫曼（Oliver Zephman）。我从一开始就是这个播客的粉丝。其实，在过去的人生中，我拥有历史学本科学位，但我从一开始就是播客的粉丝。其实在过去的人生中我拥有历史学本科学位，但现在没有了。我之所以谈到多米尼克，是因为古典音乐中有那么多有趣、激动人心的故事。人们对音乐略知一二，但实际上，如果你不常去听音乐会，或者接触不多，又该如何入门呢？所以这绝对是一个绝佳的机会，来谈论两位史上最重要的作曲家，可能也是两位最重要的文化人物，而他们的生平也在历史上交织出了非常有趣的一幕
point in history which I'm going to talk about. So I'll only touch, they were keen and we're here today, so thanks for coming. Actually the piece you just heard now, you might recognise from the opening of Amadeus, the film, and actually the orchestra here on stage, even some of the players on stage, were in that recording. Thank you, Oliver. Thank you. Now, those of you who have seen the film Amadeus will know that it is the story of a brilliantly talented man who is hounded to his death by a mediocre rival. And Tom, this is very much the dynamic
我待会儿会讲到。所以我只会轻描淡写，大家都很热情，今天也来到了现场，谢谢你们的光临。其实你们刚才听到的那段曲子，你们可能会从电影《莫扎特传》（Amadeus）的开场中听出来，事实上，舞台上的这支乐队，甚至台上的一些乐手，都参与了当年那部电影的录音。谢谢你，奥利弗。谢谢。现在，看过电影《莫扎特传》的人都知道，这是一个关于一个才华横溢的天才被一个平庸的对手逼入绝境的故事。汤姆，这很符合
at Goalhanger podcasts, is it not? No, I mean, this is not a dynamic that we have to worry about on the rest of history, is it? Yeah, so we wanted to open with a kind of a tipping of the hat to Amadeus, because here we are in the Royal Albert Hall, one of the great music festival centres in the whole world. And so we thought that Mozart and Beethoven would be absolutely ideal themes because they are probably the most celebrated, the most iconic composers in the whole history of music. But I think, as Oliver hinted, they're not just iconic,
高挂播客（Goalhanger podcasts）的日常氛围，不是吗？不，我的意思是，这并不是我们需要在《历史的剩余》中担心的氛围，对吧？对，所以我们想以向《莫扎特传》致敬的方式开场，因为此时此刻我们身处皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅，这是全世界最伟大的音乐节中心之一。所以我们觉得莫扎特和贝多芬绝对是理想的主题，因为他们可能是整个音乐史上最受赞誉、最具标志性的作曲家。但我想，正如奥利弗所暗示的那样，他们不仅具有标志性，
they are also the embodiments of a particular moment in cultural history. So the key thing about Amadeus is that people sitting down to watch this film, they know that Mozart is a genius. If they don't know that, then the film doesn't work. And the sweep of history that is covered by the lives first of Mozart and then of Beethoven, it witnesses the onset of the French Revolution, the Napoleonic Wars, the rise of the Romantic Movement. And Dominic, this is the period that kind of enshrines the idea that an artist can be a genius, isn't it? A genius with a capital G.
他们也是文化史上特定时刻的化身。所以《莫扎特传》的关键之处在于，人们坐下来看这部电影时，他们就知道莫扎特是个天才。如果他们不知道这一点，那这部电影就无法成立了。而首先由莫扎特、然后由贝多芬的生平所涵盖的历史跨度，它见证了法国大革命的爆发、拿破仑战争以及浪漫主义运动的兴起。多米尼克，正是这一时期确立了“艺术家可以是一个天才”的概念，不是吗？一个带有大写 G 的天才。
Absolutely, and that's why the lives of Mozart and Beethoven are a brilliant window onto the world of the late 18th and early 19th centuries. We'll be exploring in this show the emergence of the idea of the late 18th and early 19th centuries. We'll be exploring in this show the emergence of the idea of the genius and the idea of art with a capital A and the way in which that reflects political and social change and also frankly, the way that people make money. So it's a continuous story that we've got for you tonight
绝对是的，这就是为什么莫扎特和贝多芬的生平是一扇通往 18 世纪末和 19 世纪初世界的绝佳窗口。我们将在本期节目中探讨 18 世纪末和 19 世纪初的思想涌现。我们将在节目中探讨天才概念的出现，以及带有大写 A 的艺术概念，以及它如何反映政治和社会变革，坦率地说，还有人们赚钱的方式。所以这是一个连贯的故事，今晚我们将为您娓娓道来
but we're going to tell it in two halves. We will be coming to Beethoven in the second half. Now can I just ask, are there any members here of the Rest is History club? Very good. So you can listen to that second half right away. And Dominic, I think we should say that that joke is made up by our beloved producer Theo. It is. That is Theo's joke. Theo is very cross if people tell that joke and they don't give him the credit. So well done, Theo. He's in his own way, he's a genius.
但我们会把它分成上下半场。我们在下半场将会讲到贝多芬。现在请允许我问一下，这里有《历史的剩余》俱乐部的成员吗？非常好。所以你们现在就可以立刻收听下半场了。多米尼克，我觉得我们应该说明一下，那个笑话是我们挚爱的制作人西奥（Theo）编的。是的。那是西奥的笑话。如果别人讲了这个笑话却不给他署名，西奥会非常生气的。所以，干得好，西奥。用他自己的方式，他也是个天才。
So for now, in the first half, it is the story of Mozart and that will be told to you by Mr Tom Holland. Tom, take it away. Right. Tom Holland. Tom take it away. Right, so Mozart, he is born in 1756 in Salzburg, Austria, which is part of the Holy Roman Empire ruled by, I guess they're friends of the show aren't they, the Habsburgs? Definitely friends of the show, very much so. And so he's born into a Europe that is becoming ever more obsessed by music. But if it's an era that loves and values music, it's not a period that necessarily loves and
那么现在，在上半场，将是莫扎特的故事，这个故事将由汤姆·霍兰德（Tom Holland）先生为您讲述。汤姆，请开始吧。好的。汤姆·霍兰德。汤姆，请开始。好的，那么莫扎特，他于 1756 年出生于奥地利萨尔茨堡，这里是神圣罗马帝国的一部分，由——我想他们算是节目的老朋友了吧？——哈布斯堡王朝统治？绝对是节目的老朋友，毫无疑问。所以他出生在一个对音乐越来越痴迷的欧洲。但如果这是一个热爱并珍视音乐的时代，它却未必是一个热爱并
values musicians. And if you think of the one other great 18th century composer who can kind of stand on the podium beside Mozart, Johann Sebastian Bach. He spends his whole life as an employee. He's not a genius. He's essentially a kind of salaried servant. And in fact, when he tried to leave the employ of one of his masters, the Duke of Weimar, the Duke responded by locking him up in prison. So there is no room for playing the genius in the first half of the 18th century. There are however growing opportunities to perhaps make money under your own steam. And the person who exemplifies this is a fellow German of Bach's, but rather than staying in Germany as Bach did, this guy, Handel,
珍视音乐家的时代。如果你想想另一位能与莫扎特并肩站在领奖台上的 18 世纪伟大作曲家约翰·塞巴斯蒂安·巴赫（Johann Sebastian Bach）。他的一生都是作为一名雇员度过的。他不是什么天才。他本质上只是一种拿薪水的仆人。事实上，当他试图离开他的雇主之一——魏玛公爵（Duke of Weimar）的雇佣关系时，公爵的反应是将他关进监狱。因此，在 18 世纪的上半叶，根本没有扮演天才的空间。然而，通过自己的努力赚钱的机会却在不断增加。而体现这一点的正是巴赫的同胞德国人亨德尔（Handel），但他并没有像巴赫那样留在德国，这家伙，亨德尔
comes to the richest, the most culturally significant city in Europe, the great El Dorado of music, and that city, I'm proud to say, is London. Hurrah. So Handel comes to London and he makes such a success of it that he ends up fabulously rich and he even has a success of it that he ends up fabulously rich and he even has a tomb in Westminster Abbey. So there you have a kind of tension between the musician as servant and the musician as entrepreneur and the father of Mozart, Leopold, who will play a key role in our story, he
来到了欧洲最富裕、文化意义最重大的城市，音乐的伟大黄金国，而这座城市，我很自豪地说，就是伦敦。万岁。所以亨德尔来到伦敦并获得了巨大的成功，以至于他最终变得富有得难以置信，甚至他在威斯敏斯特教堂（Westminster Abbey）也拥有一个墓穴。所以这就形成了一种张力，介于作为仆人的音乐家和作为企业家的音乐家之间，而莫扎特的父亲利奥波德（Leopold），他在我们的故事中扮演着关键角色，他
kind of has feet in both camps. So on the one hand, he is a violinist in the service of the Archbishop of Salzburg. He's essentially kind of one rung up from a footman. But at the same time, he has a kind of secret brooding contempt for aristocratic and indeed archepiscopal employers. And as time will show, he has a brilliant, brilliant future as an impresario. And the reason for that is that his son, Wolfgang Amadeus, turns out to be a genius. And Dominic, I think your son, Sandbrook Jr., is here tonight. Is it he? And am I not right in thinking you mentioned to me that he won a regional poetry reading competition with the charge of the Light Brigade? He did. He did. And people laugh and they shouldn't laugh
可以说是两边通吃。一方面，他是萨尔茨堡大主教麾下的一名小提琴手。他基本上比男仆高一个等级。但与此同时，他内心对贵族和大主教雇主有一种秘密的、沉闷的蔑视。随着时间的推移，事实将证明，他作为一名经纪人（impresario）有着辉煌无比的前途。原因就在于，他的儿子沃尔夫冈·阿马德乌斯（Wolfgang Amadeus）被证明是一个天才。多米尼克，我想你的儿子小桑德布鲁克（Sandbrook Jr.）今晚也在这里？是他在吗？我没记错的话，你曾跟我提过，他凭着朗诵《轻骑兵冲锋》（The Charge of the Light Brigade）赢得了一场地区诗歌朗诵比赛？是的，是的。人们笑了，但他们不该笑，
because it was a sublime performance. So if you had shown a fraction of the entrepreneurial zeal of Leopold Mozart, you could have made an absolute packet by taking Arthur around poetry competitions across the length and breadth of the city, of the country. Now I don't know when Arthur started reciting Tennyson, but young Mozart, his musical career supposedly begins very very young so it is said that at the age of two he's picking tunes out on a keyboard the age of four he composes his first concerto and at the age of six he goes to the imperial court in Vienna where he meets the
因为那是一场极其精彩的表演。所以，如果你有利奥波德·莫扎特哪怕一小部分的创业热情，你完全可以通过带着亚瑟去这座城市、这个国家的长篇累牍的诗歌比赛中参赛，从而赚得盆满钵满。现在我不知道亚瑟是什么时候开始背诵丁尼生的，但年轻的莫扎特，他的音乐生涯据说开始得非常非常早——据说他在两岁时就能在键盘上挑出曲调，四岁时创作了他的第一首协奏曲，六岁时他前往维也纳的帝国宫廷，在那里他遇到了
hapsburg royal family oh and that's we've talked about that in the french revolution series so that's when he meets marionette she's very young? Yeah, she's just a little girl at this point. And little baby Mozart, he climbs up onto the lap of Marie Antoinette's mother, the Empress Maria Theresa, gives her a big hug, gives her a little kiss. It's all absolutely adorable. And Leopold is watching this and he goes, Kuching, we have got a gold mine here.
哈布斯堡皇室成员。哦，我们在法国大革命系列里讨论过这个，所以那是他遇到玛丽·安托瓦内特（Marie Antoinette）的时候，她当时很年轻？是的，她这时候还只是个小女孩。小小的莫扎特爬上了玛丽·安托瓦内特的母亲——女皇玛丽亚·特蕾西亚（Empress Maria Theresa）的膝头，给了她一个大大的拥抱，还亲了她一下。这一切简直可爱极了。利奥波德看着这一幕心想：“叮咚，我们挖到金矿了。”
And so he gets permission from his employer, the Archbishop, to go on tour. And they go to all the cities of the Holy Roman Empire. They go to Paris, they go to London, they go to Versailles, and of course they end up in London. And they have a brilliant time here, I'm happy to say. They meet the King and Queen, they hang out in Soho. Leopold becomes so kind of habituated to London life
于是他得到了他的雇主——大主教的许可，开始外出巡演。他们走遍了神圣罗马帝国的各大城市。他们去了巴黎、伦敦、凡尔赛，当然，最后他们来到了伦敦。我很高兴地说，他们在那里度过了一段美妙的时光。他们见到了国王和王后，在苏荷区（Soho）闲逛。利奥波德对伦敦的生活变得如此习惯，
that he catches a very British ailment, which he notes in his journal, the English call it cold. So he has a terrible cold. And it's absolutely brilliant. They make absolute packet. And they're not actually generally paid in cash, although there is a bit of cash. It's generally kind of nit-macks and geegos.
以至于他染上了一种非常英国式的疾病，他在日记中写道：英国人管这叫感冒（cold）。所以他得了重感冒。这真是太棒了。他们赚了绝对是一大笔钱。而且他们实际上通常不是以现金支付的，尽管也有一些现金。通常是各种小玩意儿和饰品。
So endless snuffbox, silver watches, that kind of thing. And one of the markers of how well Leopold is doing is that he can actually complain, having eaten four roast chickens on the trot, that he is still hungry. So this is very like the scenes at the Northamptonshire regional poetry competition. Right, right.
比如无数的鼻烟壶、银怀表之类。而利奥波德过得好不好的一个标志就是，他居然在连续吃了四只烤鸡之后还能抱怨说自己依然很饿。所以这非常像北安普顿郡地区诗歌比赛现场的情景。对，对。
Well, you should have thought, you know, if you'd taken Arthur and pushed him in the way that Leopold did, you could have had as much roast chicken as you wanted for the rest of your life. So the whole reason that the young Mozart makes Leopold such money is the fact that he is seen by the whole of Europe as being
好吧，你本该想到，你知道的，如果你把亚瑟带在身边并像利奥波德那样推销他，你余生就可以想吃多少烤鸡就吃多少烤鸡了。年轻的莫扎特能为利奥波德赚取那么多钱，其全部原因就在于他被整个欧洲视为
something completely exceptional. And so because he is the fact that he is seen by the whole of Europe as being something completely exceptional. And so because he is the talk of Europe, people across the continent are saying, you know, what's going on here? Where has this extraordinary precocious talent come from? And there are various theories and they're not mutually contradictory, but I guess the most, this is a very devout religious religious age probably the most popular theory and it's the one that Leopold himself cleaves to is the notion that Mozart is a gift from God and this is certainly what he tells the Archbishop you know he goes and says look I've been given this miracle by God I should basically take him out and make loads of money because it's what Jesus
一个完全非凡的存在。正因为他被整个欧洲视为一个完全非凡的存在，所以欧洲各地的人们都在说：“天哪，这里到底发生了什么？这个非凡的早熟天才究竟是从哪里来的？”有各种各样的理论，它们彼此并不矛盾，但我想最主要的——这是一个极其虔诚的宗教时代——大概最流行的理论，也是利奥波德自己深信不疑的理论，就是认为莫扎特是上帝赐予的礼物，这绝对是他对大主教说的话，你知道的，他去对大主教说：“看哪，上帝赐予了我这个奇迹，我基本上应该带他出去赚大笔的钱，因为这就是耶稣
would have wanted. There are others, however, who kind of slightly cut God out of the equation and say that he's a prodigy of nature. And this is a period where the idea that humanity kind of separate from civilization, so the idea of a child being possessed of kind of great quality, it's very, very important. So Russo, the innocence of childhood. Yes, exactly. So Mozart becomes a kind of great quality. It's very, very important. So, Rousseau, the innocence of childhood, all that stuff. Exactly. So, Mozart becomes a kind of icon for this idea. It's also the enlightenment, of course, and there are sceptics. There are people who think that Leopold is kind of writing,
会希望我们做的。”然而，也有另一些人稍微把上帝排除在这一等式之外，认为他是自然的奇迹。这是一个非常重视人类脱离文明独立存在的时期，也就是说，一个孩子具备某种伟大特质的思想，非常非常重要。比如卢梭的童年纯真论。是的，完全正确。所以莫扎特成了这种观念的一个伟大偶像。当然，这也是启蒙运动时期，当时也有怀疑论者。有些人认为利奥波德是在代笔
you know, the young Mozart's concertos for him. And so, some of these savants take the little boy and lock him up in a room and tell him to write something, and he does, and they're satisfied. satisfied and actually the ultimate proof of Mozart's genius is that he is inspected by a member of the Royal Society here in London and he gives Mozart a clean bill of health as well so it becomes apparent that he is not a fraud he really is an absolute prodigy of nature a gift of God whatever you want to call him. But there is, of course, a problem coming down the road towards Leopold.
你知道的，替小莫扎特写协奏曲。因此，一些饱学之士把小男孩带走，把他关在一个房间里，让他写点东西，他真的写出来了，他们心满意足了。满意了，实际上，莫扎特天才的最终证明是，他在这里的伦敦接受了一位皇家学会（Royal Society）成员的检查，对方也宣布莫扎特完全健康。于是显而易见，他不是个骗子，他真的是一个绝对的自然奇迹、上帝的礼物，无论你想怎么称呼他。但是，利奥波德的前方当然也有一个麻烦正在逼近。
You know, he's got to keep himself and his raised chicken and his snuff boxes. And the problem with a prodigy is that while it's amazing to watch a six-year-old play the violin, it's slightly less amazing to watch a teenager play the violin. And so what Leopold decides as the young Mozart is approaching his teenage years is that rather than emphasising his precocity as a musician, as a player of instruments, which is what he had previously been doing, he's going to focus on the young Mozart's ability as a composer. And to that end, he goes on the most extravagant, the boldest tour of all. It's kind of the equivalent of the Beatles the first time they go to America. Mozart goes to Italy, the home of music.
你知道的，他得养活自己、他的烤鸡和他的鼻烟壶。而神童的问题在于，虽然看一个六岁的小孩拉小提琴是一件了不起的事，但看一个十几岁的青少年拉小提琴就没那么让人惊叹了。因此，随着年轻的莫扎特步入青少年时期，利奥波德决定，与其强调他作为一个音乐家、一个乐器演奏者的早熟（这正是他以前一直在做的事），不如把重点放在年轻莫扎特的作曲才能上。为此，他展开了最奢侈、最大胆的一次巡演。这有点类似于披头士乐队第一次去美国。莫扎特去了音乐的发源地——意大利。
This is an age when Italians would regard the idea that a German speaker could be musically able as kind of comical. But Mozart pulls it off. He dazzles everybody. He you know, lots more snuff boxes, but also lots of Italian maestros going, wow, this guy is incredible. And the ultimate imprimatur of quality, the stamp of approval from Italy, comes when Mozart is given a commission
这是一个意大利人会认为“一个说德语的人居然会有音乐才华”这种想法近乎滑稽的时代。但莫扎特做到了。他惊艳了所有人。他，你知道的，得到了更多鼻烟壶，还有许多意大利大师惊叹道：“哇，这家伙太不可思议了。”而来自意大利的最高质量认可——批准盖章，则是在莫扎特获得
from the opera house in Milan. So one of the most famous opera houses in the whole of Europe. And he is told, would you like to write us an opera and Dominic when he is given this commission Mozart is 14 years old so if you ever wanted to hear a 14 year old's music This is your chance
米兰歌剧院的委约时到来。这是全欧洲最著名的歌剧院之一。有人对他说：“你愿意为我们写一部歌剧吗？”多米尼克，当莫扎特获得这个委约时，他才 14 岁。所以如果你曾经想听听 14 岁少年的音乐，
We have for you Mithridati Drey de Ponto By Wolfgang Amadeus Mozart we have N Nel grave tormento, which I believe means in a very grave torment, and it's going to be sung for us by Nardis Williams. The The torment that oppresses my breast I feel peace, I feel the peace of my heart. I'm The fierce contrast of the two is enough to destroy this soul. But where is love? What is this love? But where is love? Where is love? The grave tormentor, who semen oppresses me, I feel the peace of my heart. The Doveri d'amaro. Per fiero contrasto, resisto e non basto,
这就是你的机会。我们将为您带来由沃尔夫冈·阿马德乌斯·莫扎特创作的《米特里达梯，蓬托斯王》（Mithridati Drey de Ponto），我们有《在极度的折磨中》（N Nel grave tormento），我想这意思是在极度的痛苦折磨中，它将由纳迪斯·威廉姆斯（Nardis Williams）为我们演唱。压迫我胸口的痛苦 我感到平静，我感到内心的平静。我... 两者激烈的对比足以摧毁这个灵魂。但爱在哪里？什么是爱？但爱在哪里？爱在哪里？沉重的折磨者，压迫着我，我感到内心的平静。爱情的责任。为了激烈的对比，我抵抗却力不从心，
e straccia pesa, ma a parla. Doveri d'amaro, e straccia pesa, ma a parla. Doveri d'amaro, And this is the end of this love, ofardis. That was amazing. And thank you, Mozart. So, remember, Mozart was just 14 years old when he wrote that piece. Yeah, amazing. So everything is going brilliantly for young Mozart. He's got his GCSE in music. He's got loads of new commissions on the back of Mitrodate.
心碎如焚，却只能诉说。爱情的责任，心碎如焚，却只能诉说。爱情的责任，这就是这份爱的终点，纳迪斯的演唱。太棒了。谢谢你，莫扎特。所以，记住，莫扎特写那首曲子时只有 14 岁。是的，太惊人了。所以一切对年轻的莫扎特来说都顺风顺水。他拿到了音乐 GCSE 证书。凭借《米特里达梯》他又接到了大量的新委约。
And back in Salzburg, everyone's unbelievably proud of him. The Archbishop, absolutely purring. It all looks superb. Except that there are gathering clouds hanging over Project Mozart. Now the first of these is what Leopold really wants for his son. He wants to get him long-term security. And the way he thinks he can best do that is to find his son a post as a kapelmeister, which effectively is the kind of the head of music at a court. And so he takes him round various courts and all the dukes and the counts and so on. I mean, they're impressed. They recognize that Mozart is quality, but they keep saying, oh,
回到萨尔茨堡，每个人都为他感到无比骄傲。大主教简直喜形于色。这一切看起来棒极了。除了有些积雨云正笼罩在“莫扎特计划”的上空。现在，其中第一个问题是利奥波德真正为他的儿子想要什么。他想为他儿子谋求长期的保障。他认为自己能做到这一点的最好方法是为儿子找到一个乐长（kapelmeister）的职位，这实际上相当于宫廷里的音乐总监。于是他带着他去拜访各个宫廷，所有的公爵、伯爵等等。我的意思是，他们印象深刻。他们承认莫扎特很有才华，但他们总是说：“哦，
he's too young, he's too young, come back in 10 years time. So this is very disappointing for Leopold, but even more disappointing is the fact that there seems to be no interest in Mozart whatsoever from the imperial court in Vienna. And he's puzzled by this because, of course, you know, as a six-year-old little Mozart had hugged the Empress. But the awful truth is, is that the Empress actually thinks they're a bit vulgar. She says, you know, they've been going around Europe like beggars. It's very, very undignified. And so she is not interested. And then the worst blow of all, the Archbishop of Salzburg, who'd been such an indulgent patron, he dies.
他还太小，他太小了，十年后再来吧。”所以这让利奥波德非常失望，但更让人失望的是，维也纳的帝国宫廷似乎对莫扎特毫无兴趣。他对此感到困惑，因为当然，你知道的，当年的六岁小莫扎特曾拥抱过女皇。但残酷的真相是，女皇其实觉得他们有点庸俗。她说，你知道的，他们像乞丐一样在欧洲到处游荡。这非常非常不得体。所以她不感兴趣。然后是沉重打击中的致命一击——一直以来如此纵容他们的萨尔茨堡大主教去世了。
And he gets replaced by a new Archbishop who's a very different character. And he rejoices in the splendid name of Count Hieronymus Colorado and Count Hieronymus Colorado, the new Archbishop, he's had enough of the Mozart's gadding around Europe. He wants them to be what they are. He wants them to be essentially his servants and so his goal, you know, which he institutes the moment he has been enthroned as archbishop is to treat Mozart Not as a genius, but as an employee. So Tom, this is very like our situation, isn't it? This is how we are treated. They're in the audience tonight our executive producers Tony pastor and Jack Davenport they treat us like employees and
他被一位性格截然不同的新大主教取代了。而他拥有一个显赫的名字——希罗尼穆斯·科洛雷多伯爵（Count Hieronymus Colorado）。希罗尼穆斯·科洛雷多伯爵这位新大主教，已经受够了莫扎特父子在欧洲到处游逛。他希望他们回归本分。他希望他们本质上成为他的仆人，所以他的目标——他在一登基为大主教的那一刻便开始推行的目标——就是把莫扎特不当成天才，而是当成一个雇员来对待。所以汤姆，这很像我们的处境，不是吗？这就是我们被对待的方式。今晚在观众席里有我们的执行制作人托尼·帕斯特（Tony pastor）和杰克·达芬ポート（Jack Davenport），他们把我们当作雇员对待，
We like Mozart, feel humiliated, treated like servants. And this is exactly what happens to Mozart when he goes back to Salzburg, right? Yeah, well, I mean, I don't want to compare us to Mozart. Let's not go down that avenue. But just to say, there are social humiliations, but I think also what oppresses Moats up more than anything else is that he knows how good he is. He wants to test the limits.
我们就像莫扎特一样，感到受辱，像仆人一样被对待。这不正是莫扎特回到萨尔茨堡后发生的事情吗？是的，好吧，我的意思是，我不想把我们和莫扎特作比较。我们别走那条路了。但只想说，有社会屈辱，但我也觉得，比任何事情都更压抑莫扎特的，是他深知自己有多优秀。他想测试极限。
He doesn't want to be chained up in Salzburg having to compose whatever rubbish the Archbishop wants. He wants basically to do a handle, to go out there and become a freelance. And the Archbishop is furious at this. He sees it, I mean, not unjustifiably, as kind of rank in gratitude. And Leopold, his dad, is also worried for various reasons, I think. One, he doesn't want his son to end up kind of starving to death in a garret. He knows it's going to be very insecure being a freelance. I think also he's anxious that if his son annoys the archbishop, then this might end up badly for him. He might get dismissed from his own position.
他不想被锁在萨尔茨堡，不得不去谱写大主教想要的任何垃圾音乐。他基本上想做个亨德尔，走出去成为一个自由职业者。大主教对此大发雷霆。他认为这——并非不无道理地——是一种极度的忘恩负义。而他的父亲利奥波德出于各种原因也很担心，我想。第一，他不想让儿子最后在阁楼里饿死。他知道当自由职业者非常没有安全感。我想他也担心，如果他的儿子惹恼了大主教，这可能会给他自己带来不好的结果。他可能会丢掉自己的职位。
And I think also he can't bear the thought of being separated from his son. The relationship between Leopold and the young Mozart, it's the most intense relationship that either of them will have in their entire lives. And the thing that Leopold is becoming increasingly worried about Mozart's little fellow as he calls it Mozart is getting interested in girls and What Leopold is worried about is that Mozart might actually marry So this is the real disaster that he's fretting about. But Mozart, he's 1770, he turns 21 and he decides that he's going to go out into the world and he
而且我想他无法忍受与儿子分离的想法。利奥波德和年轻莫扎特之间的关系，是他们一生中所拥有的最强烈、最浓厚的关系。而利奥波德越来越担心的是——莫扎特这个他口中的“小家伙”开始对女孩感兴趣了。而利奥波德担心的是，莫扎特可能会真的结婚。所以这是他一直在焦虑的真正灾难。但是莫扎特，到了 1770 年代，他年满 21 岁了，他决定要闯荡世界，他
doesn't care and when Leopold says no he goes, oh dad I'm off. And so off he goes and Leopold can't go because he's got to stay behind with the archbishop. So Mozart's much loved mother goes with him and they head off and they go to various places across the Holy Roman Empire, not to any great effect, but I think Mozart's having quite a good time. And then they end up in a city on the Rhine called Mannheim. And in Mannheim, they stay in a house that is owned by the prompter in the local theater,
才不在乎呢。当利奥波德说“不”时，他说：“哦，爸爸，我要走了。”于是他走了，而利奥波德不能走，因为他得留在萨尔茨堡陪大主教。所以莫扎特深爱的母亲和他一起上路了，他们启程前往神圣罗马帝国的各个地方，虽然没有什么巨大成效，但我觉得莫扎特过得挺开心的。然后他们来到了莱茵河畔的一个城市叫曼海姆（Mannheim）。在曼海姆，他们住在一所房子里，房东是当地剧院的提词员
Herr Weber,, Herr Weber. And Herr Weber has not one, not two, not three, but four gorgeous daughters. And young Wolfie, he falls madly in love with a soprano called Aloysia, and the news of this gets back to Leopold, and he absolutely blows a gasket. And he writes to Mozart and to his mother and says, what are you doing? Why are you wasting your time mooning over girls in a no-hope place like Mannheim?
韦伯先生（Herr Weber）。韦伯先生有一个、两个、三个，不，足足四个美艳动人的女儿。年轻的小沃尔菲（Wolfie）疯狂地爱上了一位名叫阿洛伊西亚（Aloysia）的女高音，这个消息传回了利奥波德那里，他气得彻底崩溃了。他写信给莫扎特和他的母亲说：“你们在干什么？为什么要在曼海姆这种毫无希望的地方为一个女孩子神魂颠倒、浪费时间？
Go to Paris, go to London. If you want to make a go of being freelance, do it in a place where you can make enough money for it to be sustainable. And so Mozart obeys, and he goes goes to Paris and it's a disaster. He hates Paris, he hates the French, he hates French music, he hates French taste, he hates everything about it. That's fair enough, Tom.
去巴黎，去伦敦。如果你想靠自由职业闯出一片天地，就去一个能赚到足够维生的钱的地方。”于是莫扎特服从了，他去了巴黎，而那是一场灾难。他讨厌巴黎，讨厌法国人，讨厌法国音乐，讨厌法国品味，讨厌那里的一切。这倒是挺公道的，汤姆。
I was waiting for the gusts of laughter. I'm glad they finally came. Because we are now, and you'll be ashamed of yourselves for laughing, we're plunging into tragedy because while Mozart is in Paris, his mother dies. And Mozart is prostrated by this. He adored his mother and he is crippled by grief. And eventually he leaves Paris and he crawls back to Mannheim to bury his face in the comforting chest of Aloysia.
我刚才一直在等大家的笑声。我很高兴笑声终于来了。因为我们现在——你们应该为自己的笑意感到羞愧——正陷入悲剧之中，因为正当莫扎特身在巴黎时，他的母亲去世了。莫扎特为此悲痛欲绝。他深爱他的母亲，被巨大的悲伤折磨得瘫倒在地。最终他离开巴黎，像爬一样回到了曼海姆，把脸埋在阿洛伊西亚那温暖安慰的胸膛里，
Only to find that Aloysia's only gone and married someone else. And so what's poor Wolfie to do? He has to go back to Salzburg. That must be humiliating, Tom. Very, very humiliating. And essentially he kind of knuckles down for several years. You know, he writes the kind of dreary stuff that the Archbishop wants, but all the time he's kind of, he's pulling at his chains.
却发现阿洛伊西亚竟然已经嫁给了别人。那么可怜的小沃尔菲该怎么办呢？他不得不返回萨尔茨堡。那一定很屈辱吧，汤姆？非常非常屈辱。而且基本上他低头隐忍了好几年。你知道的，他写着大主教想要的那些乏味的东西，但与此同时他一直在暗中扯动着锁链。
And, you know, he still has his dreams. And we've got to follow our dreams, Dominic. We've got to follow our dreams, haven't we? I mean, you, as a young man, you were an academic. I was. But you had dreams of writing enormously long books about the Wilson government. I did.
而且，你知道的，他仍然怀揣着梦想。我们必须追随我们的梦想，多米尼克。我们必须追随梦想，不是吗？我的意思是，你年轻时是个学者。我是。但你曾梦想写关于威尔逊政府的皇皇巨著。我确实写过。
Recording podcasts about monkeys. And you lived your dream. I have. A nightmare, I think some people would call it. And Mozart is determined to live his dream. And the crucial moment comes in 1781 when he's 25 and he's summoned to Vienna by the Archbishop of Salzburg who wants to show him off like a kind of performing monkey. And this is humiliating for Mozart because he is a figure of great consequence in Vienna, much admired by fellow musicians, by fellow composers, and he doesn't want to be at the beck and call of an archbishop. And so he says, no go.
录制关于猴子的播客。而你实现了你的梦想。我确实实现了。我想有些人会称之为噩梦吧。而莫扎特决心实现他的梦想。至关重要的时刻发生在 1781 年，当时他 25 岁，被萨尔茨堡大主教召召回维也纳，大主教想把他像一只杂耍猴子一样炫耀一番。这对莫扎特来说极其屈辱，因为他在维也纳是一个举足轻重的人物，深受同行音乐家和作曲家的仰慕，他才不想听命于一个大主教呢。所以他说：“免谈。”
On top of that, as well as infuriating the archbishop, he also infuriates Leopold because when he turns up in Vienna, he finds that the Weber's have moved there. And although the soprano, Aloysia, has, you know, she's got her own man, there is another Weber sister available, and this is Constanza. And Mozart announces that he wants to marry her, and Leopold hits the roof.
最要命的是，除了激怒大主教，他还激怒了利奥波德，因为当他出现在维也纳时，他发现韦伯一家也搬到那里了。尽管女高音阿洛伊西亚已经名花有主，但韦伯家还有另一个女儿待字闺中，这就是康斯坦扎（Constanza）。莫扎特宣布他想娶她，利奥波德气得火冒三丈。
So he's infuriated both the archbishop and Leopold. He's summoned to a kind of a make or break conference and it goes so badly that the Archbishop's Steward, according to Mozart's own account, kicks him up the ass out of the room and that is it. That is the end of Mozart's term of employment at Salzburg and from this point on he will become a freelance. So he's in a bit of a mess, isn't he, Tom? Because this is all very stressful for him. It is a mess, and I think Mozart's music has such a quality of lightness and often of joy that it can be easy to miss the expressions of stress and unhappiness.
所以他同时激怒了大主教和利奥波德。他被召去参加一场决定成败的会议，结果谈得是如此糟糕，以至于据莫扎特自己的叙述，大主教的管家一脚把他屁股踢出了房间，事情就此结束。这就是莫扎特在萨尔茨堡雇佣合同的终点，从这一刻起，他将成为一名自由职业者。所以他陷入了一团糟，不是吗，汤姆？因为这一切对他的压力太大了。这确实是一团糟，而且我认为莫扎特的音乐具有一种如此轻盈且经常充满快乐的特质，以至于人们很容易忽略其中流露出的压力和不快乐。
But they are definitely there, and the piece we're going to hear now is, I'd never heard it played live before. I wouldn't, we walked in here this morning for the, this afternoon for our rehearsal. I heard the strains of it coming from the stage and I can't wait to hear it again. It's a piece that he wrote in Paris in the days and weeks after the death of his mother.
但它们绝对是存在的，我们接下来要听到的这首曲子，我以前从未听过现场演奏。我们在今天早上、下午排练时走进这里时，我听到了舞台上传来的旋律，我已经迫不及待想再听一遍了。这是他在巴黎时，在其母亲去世后的几天和几周里创作的一首作品。
And it is simply sublime. So, ladies and gentlemen, this is the violin sonata in E minor, and it is going to be played by Stephanie Gonley on the violin and Mishka Rushdie-Moemmung on the piano. Enjoy. APPLAUSE PIANO PLAYS Thank you. I'm So I'm I'm sorry. I'm sorry. The I'm I'm going to play the piano. That was wonderful. That is a reminder that no recording can compare with power of live music. That was amazing.
它简直美妙绝伦。所以，女士们先生们，这就是《E小调小提琴奏鸣曲》，将由斯蒂芬妮·冈利（Stephanie Gonley）演奏小提琴，米什卡·拉什迪·穆蒙（Mishka Rushdie-Moemmung）演奏钢琴。请欣赏。（掌声，钢琴演奏）谢谢。我很抱歉。我很抱歉。我要弹钢琴了。那太美妙了。这提醒了我们，没有任何录音能比得上现场音乐的力量。那真是太棒了。
That's at all. Now, as you've been listening to this episode, you might have noticed that this episode had something a little extra special, didn't it, Tom? It absolutely did. And that's because every piece of music you've heard during this podcast has been performed live by the Academy of St. Martin in the Fields. And if you were there, you will remember how absolutely extraordinary their performance was. We are thrilled to have them featured on this episode. And frankly, we're even more thrilled to be able to make that recording of that event open and free to everybody in the podcast who wasn't able to attend in person.
好极了。现在，在聆听本集的过程中，你们可能已经注意到本集有些格外特别的地方，不是吗，汤姆？确实如此。这是因为你在本播客中听到的每一段音乐，都是由圣马田室内乐团现场演奏的。如果你当时在现场，你一定会记得他们的表现是多么的无与伦比。我们非常高兴能邀请他们在本期节目中登台。坦率地说，我们更高兴能将那次活动的录音向未能亲临现场的每一位播客听众免费开放。
The Academy of St. Martin in the Fields is one of the most recorded orchestras of all time, giving more than 80 concerts a year across the world, including a stunning series in London at the historic Church of St. Martin in the Fields. The Academy of St. Martin in the Fields is offering an exclusive, complimentary Friends membership to all listeners of The Rest is History. You can attend open rehearsals, enjoy pre-concert talks and meet and greets with soloists, access exclusive digital downloads, and, crucially, receive 25% off tickets to their London concerts. To claim your complimentary Friends membership
圣马田室内乐团是有史以来录音最多的乐团之一，每年在全球举行 80 多场音乐会，其中包括在伦敦历史悠久的圣马田教堂（St Martin-in-the-Fields）举行的精彩系列音乐会。圣马田室内乐团正向《历史的剩余》的所有听众提供独家的、免费的“挚友”（Friends）会员资格。你可以参加公开排练，欣赏音乐会前的讲座，与独奏家见面互动，获取独家数字下载内容，最重要的是，购买伦敦音乐会的门票可享受 7.5 折优惠。要领取您的免费挚友会员资格
and explore all these incredible opportunities, just go to asmf.org forward slash history. So don't miss out. Visit asmf.org forward slash history and sign up today. So Tom, Mozart has left Salzburg. Does his gamble pay off? Well obviously it comes with costs. Leopold has repeatedly reminded Mozart of these costs. They are above all financial. So Mozart is very vulnerable to geopolitical shocks
并探索所有这些令人难以置信的机会，只需访问 asmf.org 斜杠 history（asmf.org/history）。所以千万不要错过。请访问 asmf.org/history 并立即注册。所以汤姆，莫扎特离开了萨尔茨堡。他的这场豪赌有回报吗？嗯，显然这是有代价的。利奥波德曾反复向莫扎特提醒这些代价。它们首先是财务上的。所以莫扎特非常容易受到地缘政治冲击的影响，
hitting Austria and affecting the ability of aristocratic patrons to sponsor him. Another risk, of course, is that he might fall ill because then he won't be able to write, he won't make any money. And even though he's left the Archbishop of Salzburg, there are still uncomprehending patrons. And the whole point for Mozart to go freelance really is so that he can stretch his wings, he can test the limits of music.
这些冲击会打击奥地利并影响贵族赞助人资助他的能力。另一个风险，当然是，他可能会生病，因为那样他就无法写作，也赚不到钱。而且尽管他离开了萨尔茨堡大主教，世上依然有无法理解他的赞助人。莫扎特选择自由职业的真正意义，其实是为了能舒展双翼，测试音乐的极限。
And I think because of that, he is seen By certain patrons as being difficult as being challenging right so there's the famous moment for those of you seen Amadeus Which a Baron is reflected in some of the sources that Joseph the second the Emperor Sees one of Mozart's productions and says it's great, but there are too many notes Yes, it probably apocryphal but I mean it it it has the ring of truth because I think Mozart really is impatient with the kind of the musical ancien regime if you want to put it like that and in fact in in 1790 so when the the French Revolution is really kicking off a fellow composer accuses Mozart of
正因为如此，我认为他在某些赞助人眼中被视为难搞的、具有挑衅性的人。所以——对于看过《莫扎特传》的人来说，有个著名的桥段：某位男爵（这在一些史料中也有所反映）看到约瑟夫二世皇帝观看了莫扎特的某部作品后说：“很好，但音符太多了。”是的，这可能虚构的，但我的意思是，它听起来很有道理，因为我认为莫扎特对音乐上的“旧制度”（ancien regime），如果你这么称呼的话，确实感到很不耐烦。事实上，在 1790 年——当法国大革命真正爆发时——一位同行作曲家指责莫扎特
being in musical terms a son-cloot, someone who wants to kind of burn down... Somebody who's wearing trousers rather than britches. Well, so that's... I mean, we'll see. Mozart is actually quite... He likes his fashion. So he might like a clot, he might like a pair of trousers. But he is pushing at the limits. And then the other problem, of course, that he faces is a more personal and more emotional one
在音乐术语上是个“无套裤汉”（sans-culotte），一个想要烧毁……一个穿长裤而不是穿马裤的人。好吧，这就是——我的意思是，我们会看到的。莫扎特其实相当……他喜欢时尚。所以他可能会喜欢一件衣服，他可能会喜欢一条长裤。但他在不断突破极限。然后另一个他面临的问题，当然是更私密、更情感化的问题，
And that is that he has gone through a huge family bust up So not only is his father alienated but his beloved sister Nana who was also a brilliant musician Much loved by Mozart. She kind of ends up so cross with him that basically communication between them breaks off and in 1782 when he marries Constanza neither his father nor his sister is there at the wedding and although Mozart remains in contact with Leopold they love each other too much for the break to be total I think that from this point onwards the love that they undoubtedly both still feel for each other is massively, massively poisoned by a kind of sense of mutual resentment. But Tom let's get down to what really matters. The point of going freelance is often to make more money. Is Mozart making more money?
那就是他经历了一场巨大的家庭破裂。所以不仅是他的父亲与他疏远，连他深爱的妹妹娜奈尔（Nannerl）——她也是一位才华横溢的音乐家，深受莫扎特喜爱——也最终对他气愤填膺，以至于他们之间的联系基本上中断了。1782 年他与康斯坦扎结婚时，他的父亲和妹妹都没有出席婚礼。尽管莫扎特与利奥波德保持着联系，他们彼此相爱太深，裂痕不可能彻底化解，但我认为从这一刻起，他们毫无疑问依然感受到的对彼此的爱，已经被一种相互怨恨的情绪给极大地、极大地毒害了。但汤姆，让我们谈谈真正重要的事情。选择自由职业通常是为了赚更多的钱。莫扎特赚到更多钱了吗？
He is making more money, yes. So he has servants from, you know, he goes from being a servant to having servants like you Dominic, like me, like Keir has servants. He goes from being a servant to having servants. Like you, Dominic, like me, like Keir Starmer, he loves a suit. So... He's always cutting a dash. He has an exquisite red coat which excites much admiration. And actually, when his father comes to stay with him in Vienna, Mozart takes great pleasure in kind of saying,
他的确赚到了更多的钱，是的。所以他有了仆人，你知道的，他从一个仆人变成了拥有仆人的人，就像你多米尼克，像我，基尔也有仆人。他从一个仆人变成了拥有仆人的人。就像你，多米尼克，像我，像基尔·斯塔默（Keir Starmer），他喜欢穿西装。所以……他总是衣着光鲜。他有一件精致的红色外套，引发了极大的赞赏。事实上，当他的父亲去维也纳看望他时，莫扎特非常高兴地说道：
look at these apartments. These are costing me more than I would have earned in an entire year had I stayed in the service of the Archbishop of Salzburg, which is of course what his father had done. But you said, you know, the most important thing to Mozart is money. I mean, it is important to him,
“看看这些公寓。这里的花费比我留在萨尔茨堡大主教手下工作一整年赚的还要多”——这当然正是他父亲过去所做的事。但你刚才说，你知道的，对莫扎特来说最重要的是金钱。我的意思是，这对他很重要，
but actually I think the most important thing to Mozart is money. I mean it is important to him But actually I think the most important thing to him is that he can test his his sense of his own genius to the absolute limits and so that the It is claimed that his reply to Joseph the second's comment. Oh, you know too many notes my dear Mozart Mozart replies there are exactly as many notes as there need to be, your majesty. And if there are, you know, Joseph II in Vienna and across Europe, people who don't properly appreciate what Mozart is doing, there are lots who do. And it's not just that Mozart is writing masterpieces. These masterpieces are recognised as such. And I think it's from this that you get in the Romantic period. Mozart is not really...
但实际上我认为对他最重要的是，他能够将自己对自身天才的感知测试到绝对的极限。因此，据说他对约瑟夫二世评论的回应是：“哦，你知道的，音符太多了，我亲爱的莫扎特。”莫扎特回答说：“陛下，音符的数量恰到好处，不多也不少。”如果说在维也纳的约瑟夫二世和整个欧洲有这样的人，他们无法真正欣赏莫扎特在做什么，那么也有很多人是懂的。而且不仅是莫扎特在创作杰作。这些杰作被公认为杰作。我想正是从这里，你在浪漫主义时期看到了这一点。莫扎特其实并不是……
He's not a product of the Romantic period. But going into the 1800s, the 1810s, people look back and they say, actually, he was a Romantic figure before Romanticism. This is a man who... He defied convention in the cause of following his art. He didn't let anything stand in his way. And I suppose the great work that most famously in the opinion of his romantic admirers
他不是浪漫主义时期的产物。但进入 19 世纪 00 年代、10 年代，人们回首往事时会说，事实上，他在浪漫主义之前就已经是浪漫主义人物了。这是一个……为了追求艺术而蔑视传统的男人。他没有让任何事情阻挡他的道路。我想，在浪漫主义崇拜者眼中，最著名的那部宏伟作品……
illustrated this was an opera that was premiered in Prague in October 1787 and it was written crucially four months, it was premiered four months after the death of Leopold, so Mozart's father, and this opera was called Don Giovanni and Don Giovanni told the story of a man who cared nothing for convention, who seduced, who committed adultery, who killed people, and he never apologises. But Don Giovanni has serious daddy issues. And the daddy is a figure called the Commendatore, whom Don Giovanni had killed in the opening moments of the opera, and who he then sees a statue of, and in a foolish moment, invites the supper,
这表明了这是一部于1787年10月在布拉格首演的歌剧，至关重要的是，它是在利奥波德——也就是莫扎特的父亲——去世四个月后首演的。这部歌剧名为《唐·乔凡尼》，讲述了一个对世俗礼规毫不在乎、四处勾引、通奸、杀人却从不道歉的男人的故事。但唐·乔凡尼有着严重的恋父情结。而这位“父亲”是一个名叫“司令官”的人物，唐·乔凡尼在歌剧开场时杀死了他，后来他看到了这个司令官的雕像，并在一个愚蠢的时刻，邀请他来吃晚宴，
and is absolutely stunned. He's sitting down to his meal, when there's a great hammering on the door, and in strides, the statue of the Commendatore. And the Commendatore points at Don Giovanni and he sings Don Giovanni At Xenateco I've now sung opera on the stage of the Albert Hall. Don Giovanni still refuses to apologise.
结果被彻底震惊了。他正坐着吃饭，门外突然传来一阵剧烈的砸门声，司令官的雕像大步走了进来。司令官指着唐·乔凡尼唱道：唐·乔凡尼，在阿尔伯特音乐厅的舞台上，我也唱过歌剧了。唐·乔凡尼依然拒绝道歉。
The Commendatore urges him to repent. Don Giovanni won't. He reaches out, takes his hand. You going to take your hand? And then the Commendore drags Don Giovanni down to hell and the last you hear of Don Giovanni, he goes, ah, ah, ah, and that's the story. Now, you don't need to say it now. You never need to say it now. So is Mozart Don Giovanni? I don't think so. I think that is a kind of romantic over reading. And I
司令官催促他忏悔。唐·乔凡尼不肯。他伸出手，握住了他的手。你要握他的手吗？然后司令官把唐·乔凡尼拖入地狱，你最后听到的唐·乔凡尼的声音是，啊，啊，啊，故事就是这样。现在，你不需要说出来。你永远都不需要说出来。所以，莫扎特就是唐·乔凡尼吗？我不这么认为。我认为这是一种浪漫主义的过度解读。而且我认为
think actually, if you want an opera that gives you a sense of where Mozart is coming from, the sense of frustration that he feels as someone who is beholden on the sponsorship of aristocratic patrons, much better to look at the opera he wrote the previous year in 1786. And this is The Marriage of Figaro, an absolute smash hit. I think it's the oldest opera to have been permanently on the repertoire. And this is based on a very controversial French play which has been banned in Vienna because it is seen as being offensive towards the aristocracy. And the marriage of Figaro, Figaro himself is a servant to a count.
实际上，如果你想要一部能让你感受到莫扎特心境的歌剧，感受到他作为一名受制于贵族赞助人的艺术家所感到的那种沮丧，最好去看看他前一年（即1786年）创作的歌剧。这就是《费加罗的婚礼》，一部绝对的轰动之作。我认为这是史上常演不衰的最古老的歌剧。这部歌剧改编自一部极具争议的法国戏剧，该剧曾在维也纳被禁，因为它被认为是对贵族的冒犯。而在《费加罗的婚礼》中，费加罗本人是伯爵的仆人。
And he wants to marry the maid of the countess, the maid is called Susanna. But the count wants to claim the droit de seigneur, the right to take Susanna to bed, before she marries Figaro. And Figaro is furious about this, understandably, I think. And the plot of the opera, there's a whole, you know, there's loads of jumping out of windows swapping clothes all this kind of thing and it ends up with the count humiliated in a garden and This moment of humiliation is then transformed into a moment of the most exquisite reconciliation. The countess who has been
他想娶伯爵夫人的女仆，女仆名叫苏珊娜。但伯爵想在费加罗结婚前行使初夜权，即与苏珊娜同床共枕的权利。对此，费加罗感到十分愤怒，我想这是可以理解的。歌剧的剧情里有各种跳窗户、换衣服之类的桥段，最后以伯爵在花园里受辱告终，而这一羞辱的时刻随后转化为了最精妙的和解时刻。曾被
wronged by the count forgives him. Susanna who's been wronged by Figaro forgives him. And I just want to pay tribute to my beloved uncle, he's no longer with me, who when I was about 13 or 14 gave me a box set of cassettes of the marriage of Figaro and talked me through this moment, gave me love not just for for Mozart, but for opera full stop. And it would be my desert islandest, that moment. But it's not the moment, I think, that best conveys the sense of frustration that Mozart felt with the social setup that he was involved in.
伯爵伤害的伯爵夫人原谅了他。曾被费加罗伤害的苏珊娜原谅了他。我只想借此表达对我挚爱的叔叔的敬意，他已经离我而去。大约在我13或14岁时，他送给我一盒《费加罗的婚礼》的磁带套装，并耐心地向我讲解这一段落，让我不仅爱上了莫扎特，也爱上了歌剧这一艺术形式。如果只能留下一座荒岛之歌，那一定就是这一刻。但我不认为这是最能传达莫扎特对他所处的社会体制感到沮丧的时刻。
Because there is a better aria that does that, and this is the last aria that Figaro the servant sings. And it's a moment where he thinks that Susanna has betrayed him. And he's so upset, he's so angry that he kind of breaks through the fourth wall and he addresses the men in the audience directly. And he says, aren't women awful?
因为有一首更好的咏叹调能做到这一点，这就是仆人费加罗唱的最后一首咏叹调。这是一个他认为苏珊娜背叛了他的时刻。他心烦意乱，怒不可遏，以至于某种程度上打破了“第四堵墙”，直接向观众席中的男性喊话。他说，女人真可怕，
They're always betraying us. And of course he's wrong. But those in the know, those who are familiar with the original French play would know's wrong. But those in the know, those who are familiar with the original French play would know that this aria is in the place that in the play has Figaro complaining about the aristocracy, addressing the count, saying you think you're so wonderful
她们总是背叛我们。当然他错了。但那些知情者、熟悉原著法国戏剧的人会知道，这首咏叹调在戏剧中原本是费加罗在抱怨贵族，质问伯爵，说你觉得自己有多了不起，
but you're not wonderful at all. The only reason that you can do what you do is because you were born into it. And so if you want to have a sense of not just Figaro, but Mozart speaking truth to power, this aria we're about to hear now, this is the one. Wonderful news is that Tom will not be singing that aria. It's going to be sung by William Thomas. Thank God. And the aria is called, Apri te un pocheli occhi,
但你其实一点也不了不起。你之所以能为所欲为，仅仅因为你投胎投得好。所以，如果你想体会的不仅是费加罗，更是莫扎特对强权说真话的心境，我们即将听到的这首咏叹调就是绝佳的选择。好消息是，这首咏叹调将不由汤姆演唱，而是由威廉·托马斯演唱。谢天谢地。这首咏叹调的名字叫作《睁开你的双眼》，
which means, I believe, open a little bit your eyes. William. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone.
我想它的意思是，稍微睁开你的眼睛吧。威廉。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。
I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. I'm not going to tell anyone. And I began to do the silly job of husband. Ingrate, at the moment of my ceremony, he enjoyed reading and in seeing him I laughed at myself without knowing it. Oh, Susanna! Susanna! Susanna!
我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我不会告诉任何人的。我开始做起了丈夫的傻事。忘恩负义的人，在我的典礼时刻，他竟然看得津津有味，而看到他时，我不知不觉地嘲笑了自己。哦，苏珊娜！苏珊娜！苏珊娜！
Susanna! Susanna! Susanna! Susanna! Susanna! Susanna! I'm Oh, yeah. Look at me, I'm a stone. These are the gods' I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool.
苏珊娜！苏珊娜！苏珊娜！苏珊娜！苏珊娜！苏珊娜！哦，是的。看着我，我像块石头。这些都是神明的……我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我不是傻子。
I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not a fool. I'm not man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a man of good fortune, a, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest.
我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我不是傻子。我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，我可不是个幸运儿，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不,剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。
I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest.
剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。
I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest. I don't say the rest. I feel no pity. The rest, I won't say. Everyone already knows. The rest, I won't say. Everyone already knows. Everyone already knows. Oh Tom, ladies and gentlemen, I hate to say it, but that is how a professional does it. Got to start somewhere.
剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。剩下的我就不说了。我毫无怜悯。剩下的，我不说。人尽皆知。剩下的，我不说。人尽皆知。人尽皆知。哦，汤姆，女士们先生们，虽然我很难过这么说，但这才叫专业人士的表现。总得有个开始。
So, thank you very much. That was wonderful. So, Tom, Marriage of Figaro and Don Giovanni are both great successes. And obviously the image that we often have of Mozart is this sort of ludicrous spendthrift. But don't they show that actually he's an extremely capable entrepreneur as well as a magnificent composer? Yeah, I think it does. And I think the idea of Mozart as a spendthrift, as a kind of, you know, a genius who in Money
所以，非常感谢。太棒了。那么，汤姆，《费加罗的婚礼》和《唐·乔凡尼》都取得了巨大的成功。显然，我们对莫扎特的固有印象往往是一个荒唐的挥霍无度者。但这难道没有表明，实际上他不仅是一位杰出的作曲家，也是一个极其精明能干的企业家吗？是的，我认为确实如此。而且我认为，把莫扎特视作一个挥霍无度的人，一个在金钱问题上
Matters is just a child, I think that that's in large as a kind of, you know, a genius who in money matters is just a child. I think that that's in large part a reflection of the impact of Leopold's letters in which he's cast as exactly that. But it is true to say that by 1789 and 1790, things are starting to go slightly downhill. And of course, these are the years that sees the French Revolution breaks out. And Austria is very much impacted by this Marie Antoinette of course is a Habsburg and on top of that on the eastern flank of the Habsburg Empire a War has broken out with the Turks So this is not good news for someone who depends essentially on kind of stable conditions conditions of peace
就像个孩子一样的天才的看法，很大程度上反映了利奥波德信件的影响，在信中他正是被塑造成这样的人。但不可否认的是，到1789年和1790年，情况开始有些走下坡路了。当然，这些年正是法国大革命爆发的时期。奥地利深受其影响，玛丽·安托瓦内特自然是哈布斯堡家族的人，除此之外，在哈布斯堡帝国的东翼，与土耳其人的战争也爆发了。因此，对于一个主要依赖稳定环境、和平环境来获取委约创作的人来说，这绝不是什么好消息，
someone who depends essentially on kind of stable conditions, conditions of peace, to get commissions. But there are also more kind of domestic, more personal reasons for the downturn in Mozart's fortunes. His wife, Constanza, falls very seriously ill. You know, he has to spend lots of money on medicine, packing her off to spas, all the kind of stuff that happens in the German-speaking world when you fall ill. And Mozart himself then falls ill.
一个主要依靠稳定、和平的环境来获得委约创作的人。但莫扎特命运的急转直下，也有着更多家庭层面的、更私人的原因。他的妻子康斯坦茨生了重病。你知道的，他不得不花很多钱买药，把她送到温泉疗养地去，这都是日耳曼语世界里生病时会经历的各种事情。接着莫扎特自己也病倒了。
And this is the real calamity because, of course, when he's lying in bed, he can't work and if he can't work, he's not making any money. And he does recover, but he's really, really short of funds. And so, 1790, 1791, his correspondence is full of, frankly, embarrassing, catching letters trying to get money out of his rich friends. And then in the summer of 1791, there comes a fateful commission, a commission to write a requiem.
这才是真正的灾难，因为当然了，当他躺在床上时他就无法工作，而如果他无法工作，他就赚不到钱。他确实康复了，但他的资金真的是极其匮乏。因此，在1790年和1791年，他的书信里到处都是坦白说令人尴尬的、四处求告的信件，试图从他有钱的朋友那里弄到钱。然后，在1791年夏天，一个命运攸关的委约降临了，一份创作《安魂曲》的委约。
So the traditional version of this story is that it's a very strange and eerie and haunting moment in his life, isn't it? Yeah, I think the kind of the eeriest, the most haunting story, perhaps in the whole of classical music. And it derives from reminiscences from Constanza in the wake of Mozart's death, and she spoke to the man who would then go on to write the first biography of Mozart. And according to Constanza, the commission to write the Requiem, it's anonymous, it comes from an unknown messenger. Mozart starts writing it and he falls ill but continues working on it and as he works on it he becomes convinced that he is writing the
所以这个故事的传统版本是，这是他生命中一个非常奇异、诡异而又萦绕心头的时刻，对吧？是的，我认为这是整个古典音乐中也许最诡异、最令人挥之不去的的故事。它源自康斯坦茨在莫扎特死后不久的回忆，她与后来撰写第一部莫扎特传记的人交谈过。根据康斯坦茨的说法，创作《安魂曲》的委托是匿名的，来自一个不知名的信使。莫扎特开始创作，随后病倒但仍继续工作，在创作过程中，他逐渐确信自己是在为
Requiem for himself. And not only that but that he is being poisoned. Now he never finishes it because on the 5th of December 1791 just after midday he dies and he is buried in a common grave. Almost no mourners attend the ceremony and after he is buried there is no memorial, no headstone to mark the place where his body lay. And it's from this that you get again the romantic myth that Mozart died forgotten, unknown, a pauper. And it's very powerful and this is why people believe it.
自己谱写《安魂曲》。不仅如此，他还坚信自己正在被人下毒。最终他再也没有完成这部作品，因为在1791年12月5日正午刚过，他就去世了，并被安葬在一个公共墓地里。几乎没有什么哀悼者出席葬礼，在他下葬后也没有任何纪念碑、没有墓碑来标记他遗体安息的地方。也就是从这里，再次诞生了莫扎特死时被人遗忘、籍籍无名、身无分文的浪漫主义神话。这个神话非常有影响力，这也是为什么人们对此深信不疑。
However, in the main, it's not true. Sorry. We've told it and now we're going to debunk it. We're going to have our cake and we're going to eat it. We know exactly who commissioned the Requiem. It was an eccentric count who enjoyed employing musicians to write pieces for him And he would then pass them off as his own so he was essentially employing Mozart to be a ghostwriter Mozart was not poisoned. He seems to have died of rheumatic fever
然而，大体上来说，这不是真的。抱歉。我们刚刚讲了这个故事，现在我们要打破它。我们既要讲这个故事，又要推翻它。我们确切地知道是谁委托创作了《安魂曲》。那是一位古怪的伯爵，他喜欢雇佣音乐家为他写曲子，然后他会把这些作品当作自己的作品发表，所以他实际上是雇佣莫扎特当枪手。莫扎特并没有被毒死。他似乎死于风湿热，
He was not forgotten when the news spread across Vienna that Mozart had died Huge crowds gathered outside his house to mourn him. He was cherished and admired and maybe because of that he wasn't really a pauper either. He was still in financial trouble but he was starting to recoup his losses. An opera that he wrote in 1791 that got put on the Magic Flute, absolute smash, probably his most lucrative opera of the lot. So there are signs that he was kind of hauling himself back from the financial brink. And although it is true that he had a very spare funeral,
他并没有被世人遗忘。当莫扎特去世的消息传遍维也纳时，大批群众聚集在他的房门外悼念他。他备受爱戴和敬仰，也许正因如此，他其实也算不上是个穷光蛋。他确实仍陷入财务困境，但那时他已经开始弥补亏损了。他在1791年创作并上演的歌剧《魔笛》大获成功，绝对是一部轰动之作，很可能是他所有歌剧中获利最丰厚的一部。因此，有迹象表明他正将自己从财务绝境中拉回来。虽然确实他的葬礼非常简朴，
that people didn't go to the ceremony, that there is no headstone, I think this reflects more than anything his personal piety, his sense that possibly is a reaction to the excesses of the Baroque, that an overly flamboyant funeral would be disrespectful to God. But even so, Tom, this is surely the most tragic moment in the history of classical music, of music generally.
人们没有去参加仪式，也没有墓碑，但我认为这最能反映出他的个人虔诚，他觉得这或许是对巴洛克时期过度奢华的一种反弹，过于张扬的葬礼对上帝是不敬的。即便如此，汤姆，这肯定也是古典音乐史乃至整个音乐史上最悲惨的时刻。
I do find it upsetting to ponder the death of Mozart so early. He dies when he's 36. You think of all the music that he could have written if he'd survived. He kept a journal and in it he was working out things that he might do late in the future and he would write up the date through the 1790s into the 1800s. So he was contemplating living, certainly, into the 19th century, and of course he doesn't, and it's hard not to feel that as a terrible tragedy. But I think also the kind of impersonality of that funeral,
每当想到莫扎特如此年轻便离世，我确实感到很难过。他去世时年仅36岁。你想想，如果他能活下来，他本可以创作出多少音乐。他曾保留过一本日志，并在其中规划着他未来晚期可能会做的事情，他一直把日期写到1790年代乃至1800年代。所以他当然曾盘算着要活到19世纪，但遗憾的是他没有，这很难不让人感到是一种巨大的悲剧。但我也觉得那种葬礼的冰冷无情，
it is upsetting. So the scene in Amadeus where he's kind of chucked into the grave and then Lime is thrown over it and they just wander off and there is Mozart's body. I do find that kind of upsetting and I think the reason for that is that In his lifetime Mozart was loved but in the wake of his death he became even more loved and he has remained loved to this day and There is a kind of sorrow about his death, I think.
让人感到难过。所以在电影《莫扎特传》中，他被粗鲁地扔进乱葬岗，然后被撒上生石灰，大家随后散去，只留下莫扎特的遗体。我确实觉得那个场景挺让人难过的，我想原因在于，莫扎特在世时就备受喜爱，而在他死后，他受到了更多人的喜爱，并且这份喜爱延续至今。关于他的死，我总觉得有一种挥之不去的悲伤。
All right. Well, thank you, Tom. That was, dare I say, a tour de force. And now to say farewell to Mozart. There is no better piece than Mozart's great Requiem. For my money, one of the very best pieces of music ever written. So we're now going to have the Introitus and the Curie and that's going to be with the Philharmonia Chorus and the return of Nardis Williams. Thank you. The The O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, and now, my spirit, Luce, odes! And the eternal God in heaven
好的。那么，谢谢你，汤姆。这是一场堪称精湛绝伦的演讲。现在，让我们向莫扎特作最后的告别。再也没有比莫扎特伟大的《安魂曲》更好的作品了。在我看来，这是有史以来写得最好的音乐作品之一。接下来我们将欣赏《进台词》与《垂怜经》，由爱乐合唱团以及娜迪斯·威廉斯的回归为大家呈献。谢谢。啊……愿逝者的灵魂安息，主啊，请垂怜。愿永恒的光芒普照，哦主，求你垂怜。合唱团演唱：耶稣，求你垂怜。
will bring back the dead man. And the troubled heroes will rise. the the the the the the The O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, O come, And let us be glad. Et luz per pechua, Luce a teis. O Lord, have mercy on us. Choir singing Jesus, have mercy on us.
耶稣，主啊，求你垂怜。耶稣，主啊，求你垂怜。耶稣，主啊，求你垂怜。耶稣，主，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，耶稣，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，阳光，愿上帝将大地留在祂的工作中。感谢您的收听。希望您喜欢。我们将在2025年的周四回归，带来我们在皇家阿尔伯特音乐厅录制的节目的下半部分，这也是我们2025年的第一场演出。
Jesus, Lord, have mercy on us. Jesus, Lord, have mercy on us. Jesus, Lord, have mercy on us. Jesus, Lord, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, Jesus, The The sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, the sun, And may God keep the earth in His work. Thank you for listening. I hope you enjoyed it. And we will be back on Thursday in 2025, our first show of 2025 with the second half of that show that we recorded at the Royal
而那场演出的焦点将是贝多芬。希望你们会喜欢。再见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
Albert Hall. And the focus of that show will be Beethoven. I hope you enjoy it. Bye bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。